[Music]
vladimir putin is waging a bloody and
brutal war against ukraine we're in for
incredibly gruesome and grotesque weeks
ahead of us
but the worst may be yet to come
as far as putin is concerned he is now
in a state of war with the west and with
nato it's just terrifying no
how far will putin go
the economists experts discuss the
threat of escalation
ed what's your take on this you wrote
this week that escalation is a narcotic
for vladimir putin one of the more
memorable lines of your leader how big a
risk is that
it's important to understand the impulse
for escalation which is that if the war
is going badly um for putin then his
answer is to escalate if he feels that
the west is
supplying too many arms then the answer
is to escalate and he's he is depending
on the fact that he is willing to out
escalate all of his opponents and drive
them off and intimidate them that is a
dangerous calculus and it's one that
that most of us are simply not used to
what worries me about putin is he has
both the willingness and the capability
to take this to
really extreme levels there's big talk
about possibly use of a battlefield
nuclear weapon
so we're in a very unhealthy dynamic
putin will act and go as far as he needs
to he feels
uh because he knows that he's got
nuclear and russia cannot be cannot be
attacked so uh it's less of a deterrent
more sort of impunity cover for putin to
go further i also worry about the
possibility of the use of battlefield
tactical uh nuclear weapons uh this is
something that is now being openly
discussed both in russia and in ukraine
somebody you know mentioned to me
reminded me of the line which vladimir
putin used uh two years ago in a valdez
speech when he apparently said well you
know if there is nuclear we'll all die
but we will go to heaven and you will
just rot i am afraid about the use of
chemical weapons i think we've seen in
the last few days russian officials like
sergey lavrov issue completely unfounded
and bogus allegations of u.s chemical
weapons laboratories in ukraine sergey
shoigu the defense minister talking
about u.s private mercenaries using
chemical weapons in in ukraine and i
fear all of that could be used as a
pretext for chemical weapons use inside
ukraine which would be blamed on
ukrainians or indeed on americans and it
would justify a major russian escalation
what is the risk of the war turning into
a direct confrontation between nato and
russia
whenever you have an invasion involving
190 000 troops on the edge of a rival's
territory on the edge of nato territory
there is a
uncomfortably high risk of escalation i
think the for me the most significant
pathway to escalation at present
is the question of arms supplies there
are lots of arms depots sitting in
eastern europe in poland and other
countries bound for ukraine and if they
feel that this this is an existential
problem for them that this is their the
future of their war in ukraine that the
west is supplying their enemy we've
already seen warnings from the russian
leadership
we should fully expect sabotage direct
action explosions against those arms
depots in europe i think we can easily
imagine
if this war goes badly for them if it
drags on if they feel or fear the west
is providing more sophisticated weapons
they could escalate by directly
targeting those sites and we could then
see a a pressure within nato to invoke
article 5 or to respond in some other
fashion so i think the risk is there and
it is a it is absolutely a real one
given that russia in particular is
willing to escalate the level of risk to
try and deter the west at this stage
which of course makes everything
considerably more more dangerous
the key
break on escalation at the moment is the
fact that nato is bound together by
article 5 and countries that aren't in
nato aren't so
if putin does things in ukraine there is
no obligation from nato to do anything
about it
if
putin has a direct attack on a nato
country then there is an obligation to
do something about it and the
credibility of that obligation is
absolutely key what we will see is
attempts by putin to blur that
commitment of article 5 to try and cast
doubt on it by doing things that aren't
quite serious enough to
cause an article 5 event
but at the same time a very offensive
and erosive and if you do that enough
you start to kind of loosen
the
architecture of nato and then i think we
get into really really dangerous
territory because the calculation from
russia is that they can go farther and
intimidate everybody in article 5 really
doesn't matter very much but nature has
to demonstrate article 5 does and then
before you know it you're in a war
between nato and russia if russia is at
war with nato then i don't see how you
stop escalation getting getting really
really bad and
i i could see that easily ending in a
nuclear exchange this is one man
with more power than anybody had in
russia since stalin i mean stalin did
have pretty much the same amount of
power
paranoid about uh his security a man who
spent uh two years from what we
understand in fact in a bunker isolating
from from covet
we see his meetings with
foreign minister lavrov and his defense
minister shoigu seated about
looks like 20 meters apart
not just because of covered but because
the security services are paranoid about
the possibility of assassination attack
now what we also have known about putin
since the beginning is that he
is a man who
does not and never has
uh accepted his mistakes and never
admitted to them
we know that putin used to back off a
bit tactically he would then sort of go
back again but
this time he's not backing
at all and uh yes i i'm worried about
his state of mind and the uh this very
very small cabal of people around him
who now
have they know they're part of this they
know they're going all the way down with
him there is no way out
what off-ramps can the west offer mr
putin for a dignified exit from ukraine
we know exactly what he wants and what
he wants is he is waiting for that
telephone call to come
from president biden
the only man he wants to negotiate with
possibly uh prime minister johnson uh
and macron
offering him a peace conference where
america britain france and putin will
sit down and say okay so you don't want
to go you don't want the war all the way
because ultimately you will not solve
anything you'll just destroy kiev and
you'll destroy ukraine but you will not
be able to control it we don't want
endless bloodshed so let's talk about
how we carve up that part of the world
you know which part of ukraine stays in
the western sphere of influence which
part stays in in russia's sphere of
influence uh
where georgia uh moldova and other parts
lie uh he wants a another cover up for
the world and he said that and that's
ultimately what he wants so what he's
waiting for is that telephone call to
come the minute that telephone comes a
telephone call comes and they they
propose a cover that putin will declare
uh as his ultimate victory short of that
i'm not sure where he stops what's the
current russian state of russian public
knowledge and opinion of what's
happening in ukraine more broadly i mean
how effective is the propaganda war
being do ordinary russians how do they
feel i've covered russia for more than
20 years i've never seen moscow being so
tense
there was surveillance everywhere there
were searches of cars people were being
followed there was talk of martial law
uh people were
in a state of sort of nearing panic now
russia is a very big country and it's a
multi-ethnic country
and i'm just wondering how long is it
going to say for people um elites in
siberia or elites in tata stand where ed
and i just been recently to say
uh you know what this is not our war why
is moscow doing this to us this
anti-moscow sentiment is already
incredibly strong across the country he
is risking destroying not just ukraine
he is actually seriously risking
destroying the uh russia itself
to read more about the war in ukraine
please click the link to visit our hub
where you'll find all of our coverage
thanks again for watching and don't
forget to subscribe